now here's a couple whose Facebook post
announcing their pregnancy captured so
many hearts it landed them a spot on the
new reality series rattle now why would
they be rattled well raising quadruplets
can have that effect on anyone by the
way and revisit them at home with their
four miracle babies for hungry girls
they're ready to eat people ask me how
do you do it I say well you know you you
do it too but just repeat what you do
with one baby three more times me indi
Esme Scarlett and Evangeline and they're
not just quadruplets
we have two sets of identical twins
that's a 1 in 70 million chance they're
proud parents Ashley and Tyson went
through 8 years of fertility treatments
that left them empty hearted until this
look at that profile they're just one of
the family's featured in the new TLC
series rattled and they became a social
media sensation when Ashley posted this
photo our faces are like oh my gosh and
it says you know thank you for your
prayers but I think you prayed too hard
and overnight it went viral now we're
over half a million followers but caring
for babies took a big toll on Ashley I
thought I was dying I was so sick in my
first trimester I lost 20 pounds I just
looked like a skeleton I was just so
sick do the epidural probably in the
other room okay and the delivery itself
was fraught with potential trauma
they'll hand us the babies we'll just go
right in this room there was 37 people
total in the delivery room they were so
tiny my smallest was born at 1 pound 13
ounces and my biggest was 2 pounds 10
ounces you know they were very tiny
fighting for their lives these days
between mealtime playtime and bedtime
for the now 13 month-old quartet the
Gardner's make ends meet with their
online business a miracle unfolding
selling swaddling blankets and giving
hope to new parents we've had so many
people that bought a blanket for their
future baby they're going through the
same
Pesky's make a little most they're going
through the the same struggle that we
went through the minute you touch your
baby
the minute you hold your baby for the
first time you know everything's going
to be okay
there's so much love there that there's
nothing you wouldn't do for that child